welcome back it's been recommended that
the labour mp liam burn be suspended
from the commons for two days for
breaching parliament's bullying and
harassment policy uh political
correspondent joe pike is in westminster
joe what's the latest on all of this
well certainly the victim in this case
the former employee of the
birmingham labor mp liam bern
isn't particularly happy that it's taken
about two years to sort this
problem and complaint out now firstly
the standards commissioner has
investigated mr burnley you can see here
then the independent panel has
recommended this two-day suspension it's
now up to mps to decide what to do
highly likely they will
agree to suspend him partly because mr
byrne and the labour party have agreed
to it but uh this victim
has said that he thinks that that mp
should be suspended from the labour
party have the whip withdrawal and there
should be a by-election in that
birmingham hodge hill seat that at this
stage seems unlikely liam burn hasn't
been particularly high profile for the
last uh 12 years his big moment on the
front pages and in the headlines was
when he left government in 2010 when
gordon brown was of course handing over
to david cameron liam burner's chief
secretary treasury wrote that infamous
letter there is no money left he of
course i think thought it was a bit of a
a joke
and the conservatives jumped on it and
the lib dems 2 in the coalition and he
uses it as a bit of a campaign tool uh
so this is the sort of the the most
headlines mr burn has made since then
aside from that pretty embarrassing
letter we now know he what he is and has
been a bully he bullied a member of
staff who he disagreed with and instead
of sorting those problems out he
basically blanked and stopped
communicating with that member of staff
for five months and
stopped that member of staff accessing
parliamentary emails he has said in a
statement this
i did not resolve the dispute correctly
with a proper disciplinary process this
constituted an ostracism which was a
breach of parliament's behavior code
which i strongly support and cause
distress for which i'm profoundly sorry
i have apologized in full to the
individual concern as i say simon we
expect mps to approve that two-day
suspension but it does seem at this
stage unlikely that the labour party
will agree to the request of the victim
in this case so i believe is a labour
councillor uh for uh mr burn to be
suspended from the party the withdrawn
and us to see by election and joe
another controversy overshadowing
westminster multiple cases of sexism in
parliament we've been hearing from the
prime minister today
we certainly have a lot of cabinet
ministers including boris johnson today
have
condemned the uh unknown mp male
conservative mp who other conservatives
female conservatives have spotted
watching pornography in the commons
chamber this was the response from boris
johnson in the last hour
well i think it's obviously unacceptable
for anybody to be uh doing that kind of
thing in the workplace would be the same
for any kind of uh job up and down the
the country let's let's be absolutely
clear about that uh what needs to happen
now
is that the the proper procedures need
to uh
be
gone through uh the independent uh
complaints and uh grievances procedure
uh needs to be activated and
we need to get to
understand the facts but yeah i mean
this is
clearly that kind of behavior is clearly
totally unacceptable
well the conservative chief whip has now
referred this case to the independent
complaints and grievance scheme some mps
are calling for this uh mp to be named
and shamed that seems unlikely uh
immediately but certainly does sign a
feed into this picture
of problems at westminster around sex
and sexism misogyny inappropriate
behavior partly
because mps are away from their uh
families they often work very long days
and there's a lot of alcohol too
joe live in westminster thanks very much
indeed